the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season our Game of Thrones
hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about a fate of the bold clever
determined and proud iron burn woman
about fate of your Greyjoy in the
upcoming season last time with senior in
season six finale but while she was
besides her brother Dion along with her
iron fleet forming part of the nurses
massive invasion force as a result of
Daenerys accepting yds offer to support
her as the rightful queen of the Iron
Islands against Iran's claim in exchange
for ers fleet support let's start the
leaked photos from filming set in
kessaris locations in castrates
will depict inflaming in the upcoming
season some of the most famous locations
of kessaris such as the plaza de santa
maria de niro cuesta de la Campania
which will depict alleyway Plaza de las
velas which will depict Street Tavern in
the market in the arco della Strela at
the top of playas on my or all of these
locations were decorated in Lannister
symbols and will definitely debate parts
of King's Landing first of all all of
these locations are connected and at
first it was a little bit confusing how
are they going to film all the scenes at
all of these locations in such a small
amount of time but as soon as scene all
these locations are connected by the
Suites and as soon as seem that all of
those locations in which scenes were
going to be filmed are on the streets I
knew immediately that all these
locations are going to depict something
big parade maybe and I could only assume
what it's going to be while I was
assuming who is going to get role in
those scenes it was all confirmed by
leaked photos in a few days after that
which happened about a month ago firstly
filming started with Lannister banners
adorning the walls of carries extra
sulfur came dressed as a typical
citizens for King's Landing some of them
were dressed as the Lannister Guardsmen
gold quotes and there were few men in
black outfits which I assumed were
representing urines man and I was right
at the moment it was pretty clear that
something big is happening and it's all
began to get along with survival of
Gemma villain aka Yara Greyjoy Indira
Varma known as the area in the show and
Rosabelle Laurent Dean sellers known as
Dean they all
arrived at calories less time has seen
the sense snakes they murdered Princess
Myrcella Prince Doran and his son and
heir Prince trystane
were phoned along with Olenna Tyrell
decided to become new allies of Daenerys
as we all know from season 6 finale the
sand snakes and Yara were sailing with
Daenerys Targaryen to Westeros along
with many others as I've already said in
previous videos also supported by leaked
photos the nearest one with her two
armies Dothraki horde and the unsullied
army will arrive a dragon stone in the
first episode of season 7 while Dana
needs with her army in Dragonstone 10
and you are gradually with their armored
fleet supported by the sand snakes and
their army are going to have a fleet
battle against your own Greyjoy which is
not surprising since they are going to
try to retake the kingdom of the Iron
Islands from urine who has started to
build a thousand ships in previous
season however as my predictions
supported by plot leaks and leaked
photos a few months ago over that team
Greyjoy has ride the dragon stone and
was later beaten up by the Ironborn man
because he ran after his sister Yara and
their Li the same snake slows to flee
battle against current in which a bar
and Amelia are going to die while alaria
Sam and her daughter Tajin are going to
get captured along with yar
all this came true about a month ago I
showed you leaked photos as a proof
which I brought to you that same day as
I've already said firstly solely scenes
from
Zumaya okay so first off I know I said
that wrong I don't know how to pronounce
that at all so if you could help me out
just comment down below
firstly we slowly seen from Zumaya
speech in the John that was insanely in
a few Dothraki warriors welcomed the
just right teen and few are more men to
the shores of Dragonstone
it was LT our first appearance from sad
this year and yet it didn't start well
14 actually the word welcome is not the
most appropriate term for that scene as
we all expected John all the heavy while
meeting Tiana
that's the man who betrayed John's
cousin Rob stark and to Queen or fell by
force including killing few loyal Starks
man at the time I was wondering where
team came from did he run from the heat
of the battle against your ratio with
few iron one man
and to report to the nearest that the
battle is lost which would explain why
iron burns for beating Tiana well we
don't have to wonder anymore so the late
photos gave us an answer as you could
see from leaked photos about months ago
on the filming site at plaza de santa
maria king urine finally appeared in
season 7 set along with gri and the sand
snakes let me remind you that all of
these photos I have already brought and
explained to you
so feel free to check out my video that
I published about a month ago if you
want any more details about that it's
not most certainly that urine is going
to beat you are in the same things but
it's unknown if he is going to defeat
them because of his experience in free
battles or because he will so many ships
and simply outnumber them it's all
certainly that Journal pledges are flee
to surf scene the upcoming season but in
return search people had to marry him
similar deal as he had for Daenerys
but at times his same links were faster
as you can see Yara Illyria and painting
will be captured utter urine defeats
them and destroys their fleet whereupon
he will breed with them through the
streets of King's Landing from leaked
photos you can see your own rage on his
horse which is decked out in in greater
looking faceplate linen yarn and chain
through the streets full of King's
Landing citizens who are welcoming their
new hero euron greyjoy
Yara is not the only one who is going to
pray through the streets of King's
Landing there also capture delirious and
and her daughter teen by this parade
victorious turn will prove to everyone
else that he destroyed an aerosolized
and accomplished his problem is that he
gave to Cersei as well which will
obviously be helping her to make her
reign a little longer
most likely supported with a marriage
deal I've also made a video in which
I'll explain you how marriage between
those two main villains is going to end
a video in which I brought you my theory
a Turing machine is going to kill both
of them
on their wedding night also from leaked
photos as we can see there are missing
Obara Nymeria these two sand snakes in
my opinion also supported by leaked plot
are going to die during the battle fleet
against current in this very moment
there are not leaked photos which could
confirm fate of Yara illyrian training
after they paraded through the streets
of King's Landing but in my opinion with
two sick villains such as urine and
see I don't even want to imagine what's
going to happen to them especially some
sense snakes which are most likely going
to be brutally tortured by thirsty as a
revenge for killing her daughter
Marcela it's going to be interesting to
see how the nearest will react on the
fact that her allies are captured and
they're probably going to be executed to
me personally the fact that journey is
going to defeat grr and sand snakes in a
fluid battle isn't surprising at all
since your own rager is wildly
unpredictable a cunning strategist and a
warrior that possess proven military
tactics skills Young has spent the last
few years of the pirate reading from Old
Town to cart and beyond
well he's Long's you by the name of
silence is the most famous ship mostly
because of the fact that the silence is
screwed by mutes as a result of your
ripping out their tongues only favored
to achieve silence from his ship as
urine said himself I need silence it's
going to be interesting to see crew off
your ass long ship special now that the
also noted Conor McGregor will be one of
the pirates belonging to urines group if
you're worried about his acting ability
you don't need to be six Connor will be
in only few scenes probably in the
background and once you have any
specific role there won't be speeding
involved in those scenes because
obviously Carnival in person into pirate
on the ship silence meaning that he is
mute your enrage also carried out one of
the opening attacks of the greater
rebellion which happen approximately
nine years before the beginning of Game
of Thrones series you don't carried out
the attack in which she destroyed
Leinster fleet that Lannisport in the
first season during lands to remember
how the Lannisters fleet burning at Glen
sport look like Tyrion shared his
memories of the raid on Lannisport 15
Greyjoy
so yeah urines victory over Yara split
supported by the sand snakes is not
surprising for me but while we are is
going to be captured I don't think she
is going to be executed while on the
other hand I'm sure that captured the
Lariat Sam and her daughter tyene are
going to be brutally tortured by Cersei
verepoint they're going to be executed
you might say that the are results of
fierce warrior and a promo leader which
is for the more yard also has her own
long ship the black wings just like
euros while it's less popular compared
to Europe long ship we
meaning that no matter of a bag that you
are a spoon captain and warrior it just
won't be enough for Yara to defeat her
uncle in my opinion in the battle urine
will only win because he is going to
greatly outnumber them let me know your
opinion on teams running after day laws
the fleet battle do you think that he
should have stayed and fight beside his
sister or do you think that he had
chosen wisely do you think there is any
possibility of your escaping or being
saved by her brother teaming with the
nurses help or do you think that her
fate is sealed
don't you think that you are still has
something bigger to do or at least to
match your father but from the other
point of view it could also mean that
you are that will bring us tea and again
it could mean that upon yar is that
theon will once again be tea instead of
being reek let me know your opinion on
all of this in the comment section down
below and let me remind you that there
are only six days left until the end of
the giveaway in which I'm rewarding one
of your wait $50 Amazon gift card hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see the next one
peace
[Music]
you